[Music]
the indian economy is developing at a
steady pace due to the development of
thousands of startups and they are not
only gaining recognition from the
consumer market but also numerous
investors from all over the world on
that note hey guys welcome to yet
another interesting video by simply
learn in this video we will look at some
of the top startups of indian economy
which have gained recognition from the
consumer market but before we begin make
sure to subscribe to our channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simplylearn
going by the numbers indian startups
have gained nearly 10 billion dollars as
investing funds in the year 2020
contributing to the rapid growth of the
indian economy now without any further
ado let's take a look at the list
first in the list we have paytm paytm is
an indian company revolving around
online payment services financial
services and e-commerce founded in the
year 2010. paytm provides the customers
with service related to online
transactions travel plans entertainment
options e-store services and much more
with the increase in online services
paytm has estimated that as many as 20
million merchants use paytm as their
payment choice it has become one of the
popular fintech companies in the world
with an estimated value of 16 billion
dollars and it's estimated to grow
further because of various in-based
services including paytm mall paytm
financial services and much more
let's move on to the next startup in the
list which is mesho nisho is an indian
e-commerce company designed by iit
graduates and founded in the year 2015.
misho has garnered positive responses
from business owners all over india as
it provides people in business to
approach their customers directly
instead of going through various
transport channels it also provides
online advertising services to local
business owners through facebook and
whatsapp
misho is estimated to have a value of
4.9 billion dollars with numerous
investors providing it with the funding
including some of the big wigs in the
line such as fertility management and b
capital let's move on to the next
startup on our list ola ola is a cap
healing service startup company founded
in the year 2010 based in bangalore
along with providing cab services it
also provides services for bike rides
taxis and local transportation it
extends its services across countries
including new zealand australia and the
uk
ola has an investment funding of roughly
3.8 billion dollars from different
investors all over the globe along with
its growth ola has also acquired many
companies to enhance its overall value
further
moving on next in line we have udaan
udaan is a startup company specializing
in manufacturing goods trade
professionals and wholesale channels
founded in the year 2016 its headquarter
is based in bangalore udaan provides
consumers with a wide range of business
options to select from an interactive
and easy app-based format where it also
provides various cross-language services
to its consumers it provides business
opportunities to local business holders
all over india
with this it is gaining publicity and in
turn attracting investors to develop the
company further
currently udaan is estimated to have
gained nearly 1.2 billion dollars as an
investment in just a few years of
operation
moving on to the next startup we have
farm easy farm easy is an indian based
healthcare company founded in the year
2015. it provides healthcare delivery
services to its consumers
farm easy is also involved in sample
acquisitions from health centers and
provides online consultancy services too
the various services provided by farm
easy has attracted massive attention
from investors gaining roughly
651.5 million dollars for current and
future projects it has also taken over
the healthcare company's medlife to
enhance its services further
next on the list we have cred
cred is a bangalore-based indian startup
founded in the year 2018.
it provides financial and credit card
services to its customers by issuing
various incentives on billing through
credit cards the consumers are provided
with reward points and benefits for
using the company services the customers
can also manage their card expenditure
much easier through the cred technology
cred is estimated to have gathered a
funding of
472.1 million dollars and is estimated
to grow further in the coming years in
the financial technology sector
moving forward in the list we have cult
bit
cult fit was founded in the year 2016
which is a healthcare and fitness
startup based in bangalore india the
company provides its consumers with
fitness related services and tailored
programs for individuals to help
maintain their well-being including
traditional yoga and effective exercises
cult fit has gathered nearly
404.6 million dollars from various
investors one of them is the
multinational company unilever
the company is also predicted to grow
further in the future through the unique
healthcare services provided to its
consumers
moving on to the next startup razer pay
raiser pay is a company that provides a
channel and platform for individuals and
companies to make online payments easier
and secure the company was founded in
the year 2014 based in bangalore india
razorpay provides services through
various channels including online
banking online wallets and debit and
credit cards with such a successful
growth pattern it has attracted many
investors to invest in the firm where
the value of the investment is estimated
to be
366.6 million dollars
next in the list we have digit insurance
digit insurance which is an insurance
sector company founded in the year 2016
with its headquarters based in bangalore
the company provides services related to
the insurance market with its primary
target being general consumers they also
suggest to their consumers about various
insurance policies including pricing
matters risk management and other
related information it has gathered
attention from many investors due to its
various services in the field including
vehicles health and travel insurance
policies raising the company's current
value to 244.5
million dollars in the market
with this we have reached the end of the
video for the indian startups would you
like to add any other company to the
list if yes do let us know in the
comment section below thank you so much
for being here and do watch out for more
videos from us until then keep learning
and stay tuned to simplylearn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simplylearn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here